mind if we speak but if you're selling
anybody
my families meet me here tonight and
we're heading north and we'll keep
heading north to life on country it's
worth the journey to be able to do
something different at
this point in time where maybe you
should be
maybe your most careers are wrapping up
um
it seems to me like it that we're very
grateful and very fortunate that we have
this opportunity to take another step in
our career and take that step together
the country's superstars open up about
the highly anticipated new series 1883
in people's latest issue on newsstands
friday there's a built-in intimacy there
because of being married for so long for
25 years and being together for so long
so there's a built-in intimacy there but
then there's acting
that comes involved in it and
doing scenes and and playing characters
but faith admits fans may find it
difficult watching the real-life couple
take on these fictional roles we play
the characters we do not play husband
and wife as we are in real life and that
may be difficult to
separate for most people but we just
made it a point that we just don't
practice we just don't work together
offset for more video go to peopletv.com